hello everyone and welcome back to
versus in the fall ah it's my favorite
time of year the air is crisp the
pumpkin spice tickles our senses and
football prevents me from having a
girlfriend until it leaves February
oh and the kitties well they're out
trick-or-treating and homemade costumes
while the adults are out spending
thousands of dollars turning any other
occupation into sexy cosplay for many
Halloween is their favorite holiday all
the live long year unless you happen to
be a resident of Haddonfield Illinois
where the only year you will live long
is the one where you take a vacation
during the oktoberfestivities you see
Michael Myers lives there and while he
occasionally does travel or get behind
the wheel of a car he prefers to do his
maiming murdering and muck raking in his
hometown where he started his career in
killing at the tender age of six so to
honor him here on versus we're taking a
look back at the three films that focus
on the origin story of Myers where he
got his Big Break by you know
killing people it's Halloween 1978
taking on Halloween 2007 battling
Halloween 2018 which is not a strict
origin story but it picks up from the
events of the first one so you see where
we're going with here look it's a lot of
candy it's a competitive Feast of
Destruction the likes of which no other
horror movie icon could match in one
corner you have the OG film from 1978
directed by John Carpenter on a budget
that these days will buy you a quarter
gallon of gas the Indie flick would go
on to redefine the slasher movie genre
in the other corner it's 2007's take on
Myers courtesy of rock star director Rob
Zombie and featuring a Michael that was
somehow even taller than his predecessor
and in the other other corner it's
2018's The Day After All Hallows Eve
directed by David Gordon green and
featuring some overzealous podcasters
that accidentally reignite the original
Mikey's thirst for killing uh podcasters
am I right was poking Michael Myers
really worth saving 50 18 on all your
shipping needs here's how we'll
determine a winner
round one box office round two Tomato
Meter slash audience score round three
big laughs round four I me mine and then
we'll do a Wild Card round it I'll try
to name with the Beatles song but they
sang about love and peace and all that
nonsense that Michael Myers really
doesn't care for he may not be as
athletic as a Freddy Krueger or as funny
as the leprechaun quick okay now kids
but he's a much better swimmer than
Jason any one of these three movies
today has a claim to stake as far as the
best October 31st Base movie ever will
it be the OG the remake or the reboot
quill I'm your host Mark Ellis I know
the answer and you're about to if you
make it through this video alive I hope
you will Let's Get It On yeah we've done
anything like this before round one box
office
well haddenfield may be the town that
bears the brunt of Michael Myers's
bastard brand of Brawn but every city
across America lights up when a new
Halloween tale hits their Multiplex and
it seems like the folks both in the
United States and abroad get
particularly Juiced when it's a
retelling of the very first time
Illinois got heartbroken by something
other than the Bears well they haven't
won since like 1985. it was seven years
before the Super Bowl Shuffle the John
Carpenter's Halloween descended upon the
masses and the returns were massive
especially when you consider that this
film's budget was eight shiny nickels in
a song okay it was actually a little
over 300 Grand but in Hollywood even
back in 1978 that was a literal
shoestring and today money that inflates
to just 1.3 million dollars which can't
even buy you a condo in Tinseltown you
know what Ken 47 million dollars which
is what that first flick made back then
when we adjust for inflation which is
what I'll do even for the 2018 movie
that first entry surges to over a
hundred and eighty million dollars and
it's always proof that maybe you kids
should look into some sort of fiduciary
investment strategy if you don't it's
your funeral if Carpenter's movie was a
surprise hit back in the 70s Rob
Zombie's film wouldn't have shocked
anyone if it did well so I guess no one
raised an eyebrow at the franchise once
again scoring a hit this time to the
tune of 77 million dollars on a budget
of 15 mil that's still a relatively low
production number back in 2007
especially when you factor in that
Halloween was a known property or maybe
perhaps it was too well known you see
the films that followed the 1978 classic
brought descending amounts of cash
before the return of Jamie Lee Curtis's
Laurie Strode in H2O raking in 110
million dollars that is some smart water
because H2 I'm sorry I'm lonely it's
your own fault and I don't feel a bit
sorry for you speaking of Miss Lee
Curtis 2018 saw her return in a revamped
Halloween that would only honor the
storyline from the original 1978 film
everything else was banished to the ret
Converse where all those Halloween three
Season of the Witch fans still Bob for
apples every Friday night by this point
in the movie industry folks like Blum
House and a24 had mastered the model of
micro budgets and Maxi box office by
leaning on scary stories marketing and
opening up around the frightiest time of
year the 2018 pumpkin was ripe for the
picking and its first weekend in
theaters smashed records with over 76
million dollars in domestic coin it
would total 165 million dollars on just
a 10 million dollar budget which pretty
much means that Rob Zombie's Halloween
is gonna have to wait until round two to
hope for a w but I will give it credit
for rebounding a suddenly moribund
franchise that had already used up all
of its iconic characters for all that
they were worth or so we thought and
giving us a fresh take on the subject
matter and anytime your movie makes five
times the budget that is a studio that's
happy they're lighting up fancy cigars
2018 scary movie made 25 times its
budget which may be the bragging rights
that could Edge it into Victorious
territory in round number one hang on
let me do some math oh wait never mind
the OG Halden
225 times its production cost making it
quite possibly the most profitable thing
in the history of things I don't know
how much a pet rock or a Rubik's Cube or
a Beanie Baby cost to manufacture but
Michael Myers he's cheap and he slays in
more ways than one no wonder he has so
many lifetime kills we all keep showing
up
1978's Halloween takes the W here and
surges ahead of its children one to
nothing to nothing it must be great
living in denial I must try it sometime
round two tomato
audience score but is that first flick
even good yeah it's uh really good but
how about the kids we know they come
from good stock but how far do the
apples fall from the tree that's what's
going to determine your winner in this
round how do the critics and audiences
feel about the Halloween family do they
prefer the patriarch or are those silly
children more fun Have you ever really
liked a girl and you just couldn't have
her
or is it crazy uncle Halloween 3 which
doesn't feature Myers as a character at
all
believe how we did it
Halloween 2018 had a whole big giant
Legacy to live up to and indeed it was
up to the task it notched a fresh 79 on
the Tomato Meter and a 71 on the
audience score that's some delicious
ketchup all around and it features a
Rotten Tomatoes critics consensus that
reads Halloween largely wipes the site
clean after Decades of disappointing
sequels ignoring increasingly elaborate
mythology in favor of basic yet still
effective ingredients I see you the
consensus there getting a little catty
but come on sometimes basic is the best
classic
it certainly worked for 1978 and that
Halloween okay are you sitting down or
walking slow in the treadmill like
Michael Myers would it's 96 certified
fresh and the Tomato Meter tops among
our contenders today and pretty much all
Halloween movies ever the audience score
is 89 and it's probably only that low
because so many folks initially watched
the movie behind two nervous hands Palm
sweaty mom's spaghetti and now the
critics consensus for the original
scary suspenseful and viscerally
thrilling Halloween set the standard for
modern horror films you're damn right it
did look at everything from Freddy to
Jason to it follows to The Strangers to
Freddy versus Jason you know those two
should team up and battle Mike Welcome
To My Nightmare well battling both 1978
and its immediate sequel kinda 40 years
later is Rob Zombie's 2007 version it
was different in terms of tone imagery
Story cast yet his Tomato Meter score
indicates a Miss with the critics to the
tune of just 28 percent just a bit
outside we have the Candy Corn kid
that's sacrilege for me just because
Malcolm freaking McDowell was in it
luckily the audience score rebounds
notching a fresh adjacent 59 which I
will point out is more than double than
that of Season of the Witch and it
places Halloween 2007 fifth all time in
terms of those franchise movies with the
audience but the critics consensus puts
the nail in the coffin for 2007's hopes
of winning round two Rob Zombie doesn't
bring many new ideas to the table in
Halloween making it another bloody
disappointment for fans of the franchise
whoa we got British and cheeky with that
consensus but the good news for this
entry is that Michael Myers he always
comes back kind of like a zombie
because you know them you get it how in
2018 performed well here and certainly
poses a threat to the Original Classic
in this match but in a round that will
be won by the best of the best critics
and audiences agree it's John
Carpenter's classic hey that guy's
pretty good right so the thing is 83
percent they live as 85 percent Escape
From New York is 86 percent and tied
with Halloween's 96 percent is you
guessed it the original 1976 Assault on
Precinct 13. Parts 1 through 12 were
apparently trash but 13 was awesome the
OG Halloween wins round two and goes up
two to nothing to nothing okay I've had
enough
round three big laughs I'll be honest
there's not a whole lot in these movies
for comedy fans despite the fact that
one of the funniest humans ever Danny
McBride is a producer and screenwriter
for this most recent Halloween Trilogy
you want to buy me a sandwich what what
is that a bun me sandwich what's what
what is that I don't even know what that
I love that about you Francis you're so
predictable so why on Earth and hell is
this round called Big laughs well you
see when a comedian gets big Chuckles we
call it killing we say I murdered I
decimated I laid ways to an entire town
on October 31st
I've actually never said that last one
after a set but we all have to have
goals so we'll actually spend round
three examining which of our three films
features the best most creative kills in
the series viewers be warned uh it's
about to get read on your screen and
those ain't Tomatoes although some
movies have used ketchup as stage blood
enjoy your French fries
that sounds disgusting Halloween from
the super 70s may not have bragging
rights in terms of kill quantity but a
more that makes up for that with quality
and it was a simpler time remember this
movie came out before 1987's RoboCop
which really changed the whole kill game
go back and watch it Michael Myers may
not have great stats here but he's off
to a hot start in an iconic scene in
terms of both scares and filmmaking
Carpenter opens the film with a
Steadicam shot giving you Mikey's
perspective as he creeps into his older
sister's room and officer he's what six
the movie's barely five minutes long and
boom no more big sis to boss you around
we also learned just how strong Myers
became as an adult personification of
evil he stabs poor Bob lifts him up in
the air with the knife and no insurance
is going to cover that this isn't a map
we also get hints at Michael's
resourcefulness anyone can win a fight
with demon strength and a knife but he
dusts Linda with a phone cord it's at
this point that I will point out another
sad fact uh he does take out a dog in
this movie this is before Marley and Me
Before Turner and Hooch before
Independence Day taught us that you can
be scary and still save The Puppy uh if
only that dog's Daddy was John Wick oh
that's a good matchup they're both
considered Boogeyman right the boogeyman
is
Wick Myers let's hope we get picked up
for another season there's no such thing
2007 saw loads more Carnage Mayhem and
Gore It's not a shock considering
director Rob Zombie's legendary musical
career has spawned hits like demon
speeding and Dragula the dude likes him
some horror and in this take on
Halloween Michael Myers is capable of
wiping out whole families he kills
Wesley and his stepdad within the first
20 minutes of the movie I will say at
least one of them had it coming then he
makes quick work of his sister with a
knife her boyfriend with a baseball bat
and then he takes down an entire
Precinct of cops not Precinct 13 though
they would not stand for that you toss
in a few nurses some guards and then we
get more free thinking from our heinous
villain he sticks Bobby against the wall
and then slices and dices and snaps
necks right up until the final credits
roll this version features the most
kills of any Halloween origin story
racking up 21 kills which is five more
than Walter Payton's touchdown total in
his best season you are so demented
Michael does come back strong in 2018
notching 17 total kills he got off to a
slow start because of the film's outset
he is incarcerated happy to pass the
time by himself on a tetherball court
but then some neck snapping ensues he
escapes and that poor gas station
employee uh look sure working at Am Pm
scores your free hot dogs and Doritos
but you also have to check the bathrooms
occasionally and this poorcept gets his
jaw ripped out look I told you this nut
bar was strong there's nothing to learn
there are no new insights all the tools
in the shed get involved in 2018. Gina
gets off with a hammer Andre and Vicki
get stabbed Oscar gets impaled and Dave
well he gets what will now be known as
bobbed uh he's stuck to the wall
interior decorating is all about having
a unique Vision dude having some
discretion all right I feel most bad for
Rey he hangs around trying to keep the
families together as they can be and he
lasts a while this is my home and I can
take care of my own family all right
it's almost 90 minutes into the movie
before he finally gets strangled and at
least we'll finally remember him as the
last kill in the film
then a bunch of firefighters are a
little too fast to respond and they get
housed in the sequel which is accurately
titled Halloween kills you're damn right
it does a lot of nut cases come out on
Halloween Mike also gets pretty beat up
in the original movie he even tumbles
out the window falling to his death
well until you look again and you see
nothing but some grassy divots he got
away as he did in 2007 where both him
and Laurie took a spill happily they
both survived look I'm trying to put a
positive spin on things here but if
we're judging kills on Effectiveness
tactics and awarding some bonus points
for creativity this round is between the
two more recent rebooties and in 2007
Rob Zombie lived up to his own hype and
surpassed the previous films with the
visceral look of the Carnage Annie Zine
takes forever but it's spellbinding and
gratuitous and him taking out the
character of Judith surpasses the 1978
version for me if you needed more
evidence that zombies film was ready for
a win you know who Michael gets in 2007
Danny freaking Trejo don't do nothing
we're both gonna regret later okay Mikey
the dude is practically indestructible
in every movie he makes delicious donuts
and Tacos here in LA and he meets his
end with a truly mean kill it's not
necessarily Trejo's head on a turtle
like in Breaking Bad bad but it got the
job done and it's good for a win in
round three Halloween 2007 gets on the
board and it's two to one to zero oh
yeah
we'll see about 10. round four I Me Mine
maybe this Beatles tune reflected the
changing priorities of the band in
George Harrison's view but here it's
going to be about Michael Myers himself
his presence his legacy the actors who
played him and which on-screen version
is truly the scariest so if we start
with last round's winner Halloween 2007
then we're kicking things off with the
largest most looming shout out to the
good doctor Myers ever Tyler Maine all
six foot nine of him stepped into the
legendary role for some intense Mayhem
in both of the Rob Zombie movies
zombie was successful with his goal of
Reinventing Michael as he felt the
character had become too stale and
familiar in the same way that we knew
every nook cranny and tendency of fellow
Hall of Famers like Freddie Jason and
Pinhead zombie concluded that this
familiarity with the character made him
more predictable and less scary and he
wanted to redefine who the hell this
person was he knew he was on the right
path thanks to a conversation with none
other than John Carpenter himself out of
respect before the announcement that Rob
would be helping this project he called
Carpenter to deliver the news personally
John's advice was to make it his own and
I'd say mission accomplished but if
someone or thing I'm not really sure
which one best describes Michael is to
be invented at all it helps to have
someone create you out of thin air thus
the shape was born out of John
Carpenter's and Deborah Hill's
imagination with some help from field
research that included visiting mental
institutions Carpenter studied the more
serious cases and his conclusion wasn't
all that this similar from Dr loomis's
line in the first film delivered by the
great Donald Pleasence make him human
yes but almost like a force that will
never stop that can't be denied Michael
is more than just a villain or even an
archetype he's the physical embodiment
of evil itself a perfect storm if you
will you can't stop people you can only
hope to contain it thus we were bestowed
the story of the most evil kid That Ever
Walked during the most perfect time of
the year for such a premise 2018 sorrow
return to that original subject matter
and was a welcome back for original
Michael Myers performer Nick Castle
there's just something special about
having that guy and that William Shatner
mask back yeah it's true the guy gets
work so does his mask Castle didn't do
the stunt work for 2018 but it's his
model that defines how Myers operated in
both films even with them being 40 years
apart the newer sequel was termed a
reboot quilt by the filmmakers but the
flick plays out much simpler lots of
scares violence and Throwbacks to the
original yet at some also gave us a
deeper insight into who Michael Myers is
and what his intentions are and have
always been 1978 showcased a kid born
bad who Grew From Evil 2007 was that
person on steroids and PDS and whatever
serum Captain America was huffing but it
wasn't until 2018 that we saw the links
that Myers is willing to go once he gets
back on his program he seemed um content
in a sort of jailed retirement but then
those damn podcasters investigative
journalists who can get you up to 20 off
if you use the promo code [ __ ] just had
to go and toss the OG mask in front of
him much like Steve Martin discovering
his purpose in The Jerk Myers had
refound his Fuel and goes to Greater
lengths than ever before according to
this cannon to once and for all take
down Laurie Strode and anyone else in
his way Laurie herself is much better
competition in this film having lived a
life dedicated to the preparation of
Mike's inevitable return I have tried to
protect you and prepare you now we have
to hunt him down it certainly was a
welcome one for us fans and a terrifying
one for Haddonfield but it's proof that
with age comes wisdom that's the idea
and in this case those additional smarts
arrive with murderous intentions
Halloween Michael Myers has always been
among the scariest forces in cinematic
history but his own legacy earned
another feather in its cap with the
reboot quilt it's always a risk to go
back to the well but here it earned more
buckets of H2O
but it's age 40 taking the round for its
first win today and it's still anyone's
ball game as we head into the final
phase two to one to one
ridiculous
and now it's time for the Wild Card
round best of the best with all
apologies to Eric Roberts and the rest
of the elite martial artists in the best
of the best film franchise this round
and possibly the match could be won by
which Halloween movie holds up is the
best in terms of story acting execution
that's literal and figurative and most
importantly of all scares if you call
yourself a horror movie you gotta be
frightening and if you want to be
considered the greatest Halloween film
ever you probably shouldn't be named
pumpkin head
one you want if you think this round is
gonna be a Michael myers-paced stroll in
the park for the 1978 classic then
you're more gullible than most every law
enforcement member depicted in these
films was a Halloween prank sure it
earned some stripes for being the first
but did you know it was kind of inspired
by another movie Black Christmas had
come out a few years earlier and John
Carpenter loved it in fact black
Christmas director Bob Clark mentioned
the carpenter asked him what he would do
if there was a sequel to the Christmas
horror Fest Clark responded that he
wasn't really into sequels but if he did
it it would be the same killer escaped
and back at it the next year and he
titled it Halloween now by Bob Clark's
own admission Carpenter didn't steal
that title or premise the script had
actually already been called Halloween
but he did go into inspiration from it
and if the name Bob Clark sounds
familiar he went on to helm the raunchy
teen comedy classic porkies which did
have a couple sequels that you really
don't need to see but how about those
Halloween sequels season the witch is
pretty cool am I right I have the
feeling that you're way off on this H2O
is also great but not in competition
today so let's take a look at the most
recent version from 2018. if it's Elder
of 40 years helped launch the slasher
movie genre into the stratosphere this
newer model was a continuation of the
notion that horror movies can be super
entertaining make a lot of dough and
reinvigorate a franchise all while
saving tons of money I told everybody
the biggest issue with 2018 for me is
that while the premises Aces and the
feel resembles the first film some of
these characters make decisions that are
so mind-numbingly stupid it threatens to
derail the proceedings the most
egregious example being new Loomis who
is so enthralled with the case study
that is Michael that he kind of
encourages an escape late in the film
just to watch it uh did you really need
more proof and did you actually think
you'd be somehow spared come on man so
many possibilities exist the film
rebounds with a throwing climax showing
us Larry strode's booby-trapped Paradise
so well planned it would make Kevin
McAllister blush
the return of both Jamie Lee Curtis and
Nick Castle to the franchise was welcome
and the addition of the always great
Judy Greer added as well toss in a
heaping helping of nods of the original
and you got yourself a movie that runs
much more than it stumbles my favorite
ode is the body swap reverse of 1978's
De Numa wherein Michael pushes Laurie
out the window late in the movie but
when he looks back he she's gone she
michaeld Myers what a play I'm glad you
got to see that 2007 leaned into its
director's bold New Vision and was a
much needed breath of fresh air away
from the tiresome sequels except uh2o
and Season of the Witch but too often it
leaned on the torturous violence that
popularized the era of horror movies
instead of taking a cue from what makes
slasher so engaging the build up and the
suspense is just as good if not better
than the ultimate payoff look at jaws
which is a great aquatic slasher movie
we barely ever see Bruce the shark but
we're terrified of him the entire movie
1978's Halloween had a much more
compliant villain with Michael but is
lurking in the shadows as much as he is
the Forefront he has just six kills in
that film but more so than the bloody
Gore It's the images that stick with us
when something goes bump in the night
Michael creeping around a laundry line
disappearing just when we thought we had
him and re-emerging when it's too late
for our victims to Pivot beyond the
film's exceptional quality itself it was
like flashing the bat signal for all
future filmmakers who had conviction and
a great story but might have been a
little short on cash just like Easy
Rider and Star Wars in different
sections of Blockbuster Halloween proved
that audiences do crave stories that
stick to our ribs and if it's compelling
enough material it doesn't need to cost
a fortune and for that movie to still
deliver in terms of technique
performances pacing and above all else
scares is proof that some movies can
transcend their own generation to become
Timeless much to the Chagrin of everyone
that lives in Haddonfield again I cannot
stress this enough go on vacation what
are we gonna do
Castle Halloween
1978's Halloween wins the Wild Card
round and thus takes the match sometimes
I can't tell the difference between your
stupidity and your ignorance congrats to
the OG but keep in mind anytime you make
a successful horror movie or remake one
that Delights audiences by you know
frightening the crap out of us you've
done your job you're all winners here
today the only loser is probably me
because I've upset two Halloween movies
and one super tall Michael Myers I'm
gonna sleep with one eye open and I will
remind everyone that this is just my
opinion give me your take at Mark Ellis
live and stay tuned right here at Rotten
Tomatoes for all the latest and greatest
in terms of scary stuff streaming in
movie theaters on television enjoy
thanks for watching versus I'm Mark
Ellis and enjoy your vacation
Haddonfield halloweeners go somewhere
else
not California though because I live
here and Mikey did come out west one
time in H2O so me I'll be in Barbados
until Thanksgiving
treat no trick